jun zhang is our next speaker and her
title for this afternoon is the effects
of topology on epidemics neuron
communication and other replicate
facebook twitter linkedin you know me a
decade these social networks has become
pervasive in our everyday lives the
ideas that we need to understand
networks which shows the interconnection
the relationship between multiple people
or multiple objects it's similarly
sweeping across academia in vastly
different disciplines such as sociology
epidemiology chemistry neurobiology or
computer science a lot of recent
research has been devoted to try to
understand what useful information is
embedded in these networks for example
this one here that there is useful
information it's pretty easy to see
suppose were interested in understanding
how the flu spreads through a population
now if everyone just stays indoors and
doesn't go outside then only a few
people will become sick the network
which represents the contact
relationship in this population it's one
where no one is connected I've on the
other hand everyone goes off suicide and
shakes hands with everyone else in the
population it is pretty easy to see that
the flu will get spread around pretty
quickly we call the network which
represents this type of compact
relationship where each person is
interacts with everyone else the
complete graph now obviously the real
world is somewhere between these two
extreme cases and that is the goal of my
research to develop mathematical models
which will give us the insight into how
network structures affects the
propagation of viruses or units of
information through a population this is
the challenging problem because our
current existing mathematical tools are
really good at analyzing for the two
extreme cases we don't really know yet
as to how to deal with more realistic
network structures but it's important
that we develop models and tools to do
this
because research have shown that once we
go beyond the two extreme cases while
we're no one's connected or everyone's
connected then we start to see some
really interesting and unexpected
behavior that we observe in the real
world but previously we could not
explain with mathematical models and
when we do have models that give us
insights into how network structure
affects the propagation of virus or
inflammation through a population then
we can begin to better develop tools
that ultimately may prevent epidemics or
halt black holes in the power grid or
even give us a better understanding of
the human brain